هذه الليله الصعبه شعب اسرائيل
جميعا في اس اسى
العائلات
ل سامر طلال لحمه الله والون شمري لحمه
الله الذين فقدوا اعزا في ظروف صعبه جدا
وفي ماساء والم شديد
في خلال يوم السبت تحدثت مع العائلات
الثلاثه وتحدثت مع الاباء وايضا جزء من
الامهات
والاخوان وسمعت الالم الذي
لديهم وهي امور صعبه جدا وفي البدايه
للعائلات وايضا صعبه بالنسبه لي
شخصيا يا وزير للدفاع انا اتحمل المسؤوليه
لكل ما يحدث في جهاز الامن وكل ما يحدث في
الحرب وايضا على الانجازات وايضا على
الاثمان وايضا على الاخطاء الصعبه هكذا
كان
وهكذا ايضا في الحادث بالامس هذا الحادث
الذي لم يرغب جنود جيش الدفاع في الوصول
اليه ولكن الاخطاء
صعبه في ه السعات الاخيره انهى جيش الدفاع
تحقيق
اولي والاعتبارات ونتائج التحقيق نقلها
الى القاده والقاده سيدرسون ذلك وينقلون
الى الجنود وانا امل ان يتم استيعابهم
بسرعه وان يتحدث عن عمليه حرب مع المئات
والكثير من الجنود والقاضى والاحداث
الصعبه وايضا هي موجوده في كل انحاء قطاع
غزه حي الشجاعيه هي هو حي ارهابي
الشجاعيه هناك هجوم علينا في السابع من
اكتوبر لكن ايضا في احداث اخرى كثيره هو
جيش الدفاع حاربت في قبل سنوات في حي
الشجاعيه والقتال كانت صعبه دائما في هذه
في هذا الحي الان الارهاب كان في كل منطقه
وفي كل بيت وايضا
العاب مفخخه من اجل ان يصل الجنود ان
يصلون اليها وان يكون هناك كمين وشرق وان
يكون هناك ان يتم صيحات اطفال من اجل ان
يصل الجنود وهناك يطلقوا العبوات الناسفه
هذا ما يحدث كل الوقت يجب ان نفهم الظروف
الذي التي يعمل فيها
الجنود مرات كثيره خلال خدمتي العسكريه
فقدت قاده وزملاء في السلاح وايضا كنت
اسيطر عليهم هذه احداث صعبه وايضا جزء
منها بالقرب مني وايضا زملاء سقطوا في
القتال وجزء من
خلال هذا الحادث احد الاحداث الماساويه
الصعبه التي حدثت
لي كانت من كنا قريبين من الانتصار او
النصر الذي كان الجنود لم يعرفوا ذلك وهذا
حادث صعب يجب
ان
ثمن الحرب كبير جدا ونحن ندفعه يوما بيوم
ولكن من كل من يعرف كيف تدير الامور وانت
تحارب بعداله وانت تعرف ان تحارب من اجل
هدف سليم نحن يجب علينا ان ندفع الثمن
ونحن مستعدين لذلك حتى تحقيق الانتصار
الكامل في هذه الحرب وفي شقه العسكري هو
السلطوي
وايضا اعاده كافه المخطوفين الى الوطن الى
عائلاتهم انا اؤمن بصدق طريقنا وانا اعرف
اننا نحارب هذه الحرب العادله الاكثر
عداله التي يمكن ان نحاربها الامه يمكن ان
تحاربها ضد منظمه شر وضد منظمه اشرار وضد
من قتل اولادنا وايضا اراد لنا
وخطف نسائنا ومسنين يجب علينا ان ننتصر
العمليه البريه في غزه هناك انجازات كثيره
وفي راسها الضغط الكبير الذي نقوم به من
اجل القضاء على الاف المخربين
وقياداتهم وايضا
من مناطق السيطره
والقياده نحن نصل الى داخل الانفاق من تحت
الارض ومن فوق الارض وقواتنا تعمل في هذه
المناطق ولكن هذا الضغط هو الذي مكننا من
الوصول الى اطار الذي اعاد 100 من ع من
المخطوفين الى بيوتهم وهذا الامر في ما
يفهمه حماس هو القوه وايضا لما كنا نقف
على الجدار هذا لم يحدث يجب ان كنا ان
ننتصر ننتظر الى هذا
واحد
الم فقدنا كل ما يمكن ان نحققه الضغط حقق
هدفين ولكن لاسنا لاسف هناك
اثمان
قواتنا تحارب كل
يوم من تحت الارض يقومون بعمليات مثيره
سيتم الحديث عنها ويصلون الى اهداف وايضا
من ناحيه
اخرى هناك مخاطر كبيره في كل المناطق هناك
يضحون بانفسهم
وعليه علينا جميعا ان نقف وراءهم وان نعرف
ان هؤلاء ابنائنا وابائنا يحاربون وليس
فقط في قطاع غزه وايضا في الشمال وفي
المركز ايضا جنود الاحتياط والنظامي
يقومون بعمل مقدس في لكن في الحرب هناك
اثمان انا اعرف ان هذه ساعه صعبه في هذا
اليوم ساعه صعبه للجميع وايضا ساعه
المحاربين الموجودين في قطاع غزه وانا
اطلب ان اقويه وان احيم وان اقدر ما
يقومون به وان اشجعهم على المواصله حتى
تحقيق الانتصار الحاسم التفكيك حماس
واعاده المخطوفين الى الوطن هذه الحرب
ستكون حرب طويله وتكون متواصله وهذه حرب
التصميم الوطني والرغبه الوطنيه التي
ستقضي على الجانب الاخر لان العدل العدل
والحقيقه موجوده معنا ونحن نحدد الاتجاه
مقابل الشر
وعليه سنجد هذه القوه من اجل ان نصر الى
الانتصار في الحرب انا اقول لكم بطريقه
واضحه هنا ما تم تاكيده هنا ان هذه الحرب
حتى الان وسيتم التاكيد على ذلك عندما
يقوم جيش الدفاعي عمل وموجود وراءه شعب
اسرائيل وموحد في كل فئاته
والاتصال بين القياده في المستوى السياسي
والعسكري وايضا في الميدان لا يوجد قوه
توقف هنا توقف جيش الدفاع من الوصول الى
كل مكان في قطاع غزه وعندما نقرر لكل مكان
ولكل مهمه في الشرق الاوسط باذن الله
سننتصر